for months now it's been nothing but
hype for avengers endgame but some fans
of steady enthusiasm took a slight dip
in the days leading up to the theatrical
launch of the superhero epic when they
learn that endgame would go against the
Marvel movie green and not feature a
post-credits scene we're treading into
spoiler territory both for the
experience of watching Avengers endgame
on the big screen and for the movie
itself if you haven't yet seen the film
and want to walk in without knowing a
single thing turn your attention away
now last warning many who saw the film
and early screenings got a bit up in
arms over the lack of an end credit
stinger but as it turns out there are a
few very intriguing reasons why it's
still we're staying in your seat to
watch the end game credits the whole way
through after the beautiful closing shot
of endgame fades to black the credits
start to roll important names like Joe
and Anthony Russo the directors of
infinity war and endgame and Kevin Feige
the president of Marvel Studios who has
produced all of the films in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe pop up on screen then
we're a mid-credits scene would normally
fit there's a gorgeous tribute to the
principal cast and guest stars of
endgame everyone you know and love is
featured except for the six main
Avengers who get their own special
tribute Iron Man actor Robert Downey jr.
Captain America star Chris Evans Thor
actor Chris Hemsworth Bruce Banner slash
Hulk star Mark Ruffalo Black Widow
actress Scarlett Johansson and Hawkeye
actor Jeremy Renner each get
heartwarming video tributes featuring
breathtaking new artwork the stars
signature swipe across the screen making
for an homage both well-deserved and
quite emotional particularly considering
the events of Avengers and game that
viewers witnessed just before but that's
not all the credits don't entirely
resume to business as usual from there
on we advise audiences keep their butts
in their seats until the lights come on
plus they miss an expertly placed MCU
Easter Egg at the tail end of the
credits right when it seems no other
movie making details will scroll on
screen keep your ears open immediately
after the Marvel logo appears where a
true post-credit scene what
traditionally be placed a familiar sound
rings out
it may seem inconsequential to some but
for die-hard Marvel fans this sound
effect means a great deal
Toni making an enormous sacrifice for
the greater good and Avengers endgame
something that the genius billionaire
playboy philanthropist likely would have
never done in his earlier years means
the MCU as viewers have known it thus
far and with Iron Man as well the split
second sound lets Iron Man be the
stopping point just as he was the
starting one all those years ago though
it may not be a full one post-credit
scene as marvel lights are used to
seeing it's arguably more poignant than
those sequences have ever been with
Avengers and game forgoing a
post-credits scene the MCU is sealing
ahead without any dangling threads
trailing behind it the franchise isn't
ready to begin its fourth phase just yet
as Feige has stated that it's actually
the Spidey sequel spider-man far from
home that marks the end of the third
phase so there is technically one future
in face film to tease however a game is
the coming together of the MCS 11-year
saga and it would feel incredibly silly
to tack on a sequence setting up
spider-man's next adventure 1 because he
wasn't in the movie until the final act
and 2 because the Spidey Center tease
would be pretty jarring to see after the
emotional roller coaster that was
endgame Marvel will leave the phase for
teasing up to far from home
when that film swings into theaters this
July and everyone is better for it
before that no rewatch and game as many
times as your heart desires and be on
alert for the small but significant
sound at the end of the credits check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about the
MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]